welcome to the
show i'm your host paul aka the guy
who's been sweating like kevin feige
after i saw this brand new batman
trailer it's filled with easter eggs
hidden details and a lot of callbacks to
the comics that we're going to be
breaking down in this video full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined then i
recommend that you check out now if you
enjoy the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
smash the subscribe one like it's jason
todd's head without the way bit of a
dark knight joke there now let's get
into the batman trailer
okay so the last time we had a proper
look at the film was during the first dc
fandom over a year ago it's been a long
halloween waiting until this october but
we now have one of the most conclusive
looks at the film that we'll get before
it releases in march when the initial
panel dropped matt reeves confirmed that
he'd only filmed 25 of the movie at the
time but it's now fully wrapped and we
know a lot of things about the film
according to leaks from the screening
this will be an almost three hour epic
that is somewhat of a detective noir
film batman will narrate major parts of
the movie and this is of course a not to
not only the genre but also how the
characters comics are in general the
dark knight returns especially is filled
with inner monologues and it's nice that
they've managed to bring these two
things together batman will also wrestle
with killing and according to leaks on
the movie he will come close to it but
not actually do it what we know for
definite though is that this is a very
brutal batman who will use pipes and any
weapons he can find to kick the crap out
of criminals hopefully he pays for their
hospital builds too as yes some of this
combat it is pretty bad now one of the
big things to take from the trailer is
that we hear his voice and it sounds
slightly modulated but not to the point
that it's completely distorted i really
like this rendition and for me it's up
there with what i imagine batman to
sound like when i read batman year one
now the trailer itself was worth sitting
through three hours of flew fleur borg
stand up for we open in a diner and this
seems like it was pulled from the
beginning of arkham night what we catch
is the police arresting edward nashton
who leaves behind his signature riddle
mark in a cappuccino later on we see
batman questioning him as he's
imprisoned and there's a lot of silence
of the lamb's vibes from this on his
shirt you might also notice that it says
hospital so it's possible that he was
taken to arkham which in this universe
is a psychiatric institute clearly
riddler has set things up around the
city and is very much terrorizing it
with his insignia i actually think this
coffee might be somewhat of a clue and
that it could hold reference in a future
riddle with either the location or
something dropped here being of some
importance he's taken in by gordon and
his men which is when we go to the
warner brothers logo and also watch the
bat signal being lit up these moments
are all very important as they show that
batman is actually working with the
police i believe that there will be a
strained relationship with them because
we know from the first trailer that
bruce has to escape somewhere as the
police fire upon him and it could be
that the riddler frames batman for
something it also looks like they chase
him off gotham tower whilst he wears a
wingsuit this is such an amazing scene
and it showcases how gotham is really
batman's playground now according to
other leaks from the screening that were
dropped on twitter the riddler will be
very much a jigsaw type figure that puts
people in impossible traps that
ultimately lead to their deaths this was
seen in the first trailer with the
explosive collar on the d.a and this was
actually based on the real life one that
was used in a robbery if you want to
know more about this and i definitely
recommend that you check out the netflix
documentary evil genius as it's a very
harrowing tale that they're clearly
pulling from
now just in the same way that batman is
a symbol for the city riddler is very
much seen in the same vein and we catch
some footage of him which says that he's
live streaming it also seems like he's
gained a lot of followers who are of
course sick of the corruption in gotham
now cutting back to the bat signal and
bruce very much remarks on it and how
it's not just a call it's also a warning
all criminals should be terrified to be
out there and thus they've resorted to
hiding amongst gangs which we catch in
the next shot now this is actually the
penguins gang which we can tell due to
their black and white face paint they
attempt to beat batman but he completely
outmatches them and we see a moment from
the first trailer in which he was shot
this kind of shows just how bulletproof
the armor is and later on we see that
it's capable of deflecting machine gun
ammo bruce says in the dark knight
returns that he wears an emblem on the
chest because people would aim for that
instead of his face we definitely get
that idea in these two shots as that's
exactly what the criminals go for it
works well as the second shot misses and
allows bruce to use a deafening
electronic device that might be based
upon sonar technology which is of course
similar to a submarine now batman goes
to visit riddler and we see that he's
causing terror within the city matt
reeves said that during the costume test
said he put black eye makeup on and
whenever we've seen this in a film
before when bruce has taken the mask off
there's been nothing underneath it i'm
glad they finally acknowledged it as
it's such a cool bit of character design
and shows sort of just how unhinged that
he is now as for the major plot of the
film according to the leaks on it the
movie will pull from books like the long
halloween batman earth 1 and some of the
more grounded year 2 stories i actually
have a big theory that this story is
also going to bring a lot of elements of
dark victory in as well and in case you
don't know it's actually the direct
sequel to long halloween the long
halloween involved the killer called
holiday who murdered members of the
mafia on holidays throughout the year
dark victory was somewhat a flip on that
as it had a new serial killer emerging
in gotham who struck policemen and high
ranking officials judging by what the
riddler is doing he's attacking people
like the mayor the commissioner d.a and
so on in order to bring and end of the
corruption in gotham now beyond this the
cover of dark victory is very similar
aesthetically to the recently released
posters they all dropped through the
week and showed images of batman against
a striking red background the image of
the riddler also feels somewhat similar
to the covers that are in the book and
it all ties together pretty neatly in my
opinion now in addition to this matt
reeves put out a tweet yesterday when
promoting the posters that said what's
black and blue and dead all over this
could be nightwing however it could also
be a reference to the police force being
taken out by the riddler in the trailer
the riddler does say that he means
batman but i think this might be cropped
from another moment in the movie or it
could just be him referring to how
batman is the law i actually think that
he's going to be saying this to savage
during one of his many murders and
savage is actually the commissioner in
this movie obviously let me know your
thoughts below but that just makes a lot
of sense to me now in the book it's
revealed that it's actually falcone's
daughter sofia who is behind the killing
this somewhat juxtaposes the reveal in
long halloween in which is his son
alberto who's carrying out the crimes in
the movie we know that selena will be
his daughter and though i don't think
she's a serial killer it all kind of
ties everything together the long
halloween also has a side tangent called
when in rome which features catwoman
looking for a father and it turns out to
be falcone so yeah it's all connected
now according to sorry it's really late
now according to leaks and well just the
way the trailer looks in general bruce
will actually be in his batman persona
most of the time and he won't actually
care about appearing normal this is his
mission and he'll stop at nothing to
make sure that it's carried out this
also goes back to the comics as it was
in both earth one and zero year and he
didn't really put focus on his bruce
wayne persona however come the close of
the books alfred convinced him that it
would be useful as it would allow him to
infiltrate the upper elite circles of
gotham and that seems to make a lot of
sense from what we see here now at this
point we catch batman looking over the
gotham skyline just as the sun is
setting it's rare that we see batman
actually out in the day i feel this
moment is the character watching the sun
go down which will allow him to be able
to hunt in the shadows there's an almost
vampiric feel to it and the gothic
structure of the city definitely lends
itself to that notion i love the way
that the golden sun illuminates the
buildings and it feels very much like
his hunting grounds nareevs has said
that he's taking elements of the glasgow
skyline and then used cgi to bring it
closer to what he envisions gotham as
glasgow is a lovely city filled with
lots of architecture that gives it an
atmosphere and i think this design is
all spot on we also got an early look at
selena kyle and rather than going the
sort of street hustler route with her
that was prevalent in year one you can
see how they've leaned into the balcony
daughter aesthetic to make a sleek
stunning thief that will steal your
heart and mine just don't tell the wife
[Music]
now i love seeing these moments in
action now and it just adds so much to
the aesthetic her catwoman has two looks
in the trailer namely her short hair one
and also one where she wears wigs this
very much speaks to how she has two
sides to her personality which is of
course a comment on her character we see
somewhat of the relationship between
selena and bruce as there's a lot of
passion but also a lot of fighting it's
clear they've really worked on the
chemistry between the pair and i just
buy them as a couple and really want to
ship them so what kids say i don't know
i'm 33. now we also get a look at
penguin in which he stares over the city
and at that moment it currently belongs
to him and his criminal empire we catch
andy circus's alfred and it's a much
gruffer version than what we've ever
seen before this seems like it's pulling
from earth 1 due to the costume design
and he actually helped to train bruce
after accepting that he was fully
committed to his mission he also had a
prosthetic leg so it'll be interesting
to see if that's brought across as it
kind of hints to the character's past
and what he went through on his many
combat missions now in the trailer he
has a scar on his eye i'm guessing that
this is just a very subtle nod to his
past he says that if this continues it
won't be long until bruce has nothing
left and this is very much the stance
that he took in the comics alfred is of
course somewhat of a father to bruce and
he cares about him a lot so it makes
sense why he wouldn't want him doing
this now we could do a skyward shot of
bruce mapping out the clues that have
been left by the riddler and this
includes the sins of my father no more
lies coulson savage mitchell and renewal
is a lie colton is the film's d.a and as
we've said savage is its commissioner so
i'm guessing that these are victims of
the riddler gordon is a lieutenant in
this film and the commissioner being
killed will leave room for him to take
his place the other clues especially the
father one relates to bruce and i
believe that the renewal is a like
comment is talking about the industrial
side of gotham going through renovation
potentially this is simply to line the
pockets of the elite and thus the
riddler is trying to destroy the
corruption that the wanes may have been
a part of cut to what i believe is the
iceberg lounge aka the penguins club
here he comes face to face with the
villain who doesn't seem that shook by
him it's completely brutal and we have
heard that there are fights at the
iceberg lounge so this moment lines up a
lot with the leaks batman uses pipes in
anything at its disposal to go
toe-to-toe with people and it's such a
brutal brutal moment now we catch
another one of catwoman's wigs and she
goes in disguise before a marking on
bruce's mask this shows the similarities
between the two and she says maybe
they're not so different which is a line
normally uttered by villains cementing
the complexity of her character catch
batman not even needing to move faster
than a speeding bullet and more of the
batmobile chase from the first trailer
now we know that catwoman is going to be
riding on a motorbike and the penguin
will probably be chasing after her which
batman will also be pursuing i'm kind of
guessing that she sneaks into his club
steals something and then he goes after
her which makes batman follow right
behind them we also catch a very muddy
and beaten up looking batman and i
believe this happens either at the end
of the film or immediately after the
explosion at the mayor's funeral this
would explain the damage on his batsuit
and also why he looks like he's had
better days than us sitting for three
hours and then hearing linda carter
talking about a song she wrote go on
linda give us a song yeah do a rap go on
do a wrap now finally we close out with
the car chase which i think we'll follow
on immediately from the club scene we
know that penguin is being played by
colin farrell and he said that he has a
rather short part in the movie so i'm
guessing that this will last about one
scene i'd love to see him pop up
throughout the films like scarecrow did
in the dark knight trilogy i think that
would be the best way to use the
character he thinks he's got batman but
like a phoenix from the flames he comes
crashing through in what looks like
imagery ripped right out of arkham
knight batman struts towards the
overturned car looking like death
himself and thus it ends this absolutely
incredible trailer now before we go into
my reaction i just want to kind of clear
something up as i know a lot of you
wanted me to cover the full dc fandom
event i tried doing that last year and
in the end just resorted to doing cam
reactions the entire day and though it
did okay i kind of felt like i could
have put more effort into the videos but
there was just so much to cover so for
this year i went up doing the two and in
the end it just decided last minute i'd
rather put out the best video i can then
try and cover five different things and
for the videos to all be terrible which
let's be honest they would have been now
i have been watching the panels and i'm
really excited for the future but yeah i
just thought i'd give you a reason why
my upload feed is looking better than
bruce wayne's parents that being said
it's also pretty late in the uk so i do
kind of want to circle back around to
this trailer and do an even more
in-depth breakdown later in the week now
as with my thoughts on it i was
absolutely blown away by this new look
and again i feel like this is going to
be an incredible film that shows us what
dc can do best we really don't need the
studio trying to be marvel and they
actually have the freedom to explore
things that marvel can't because of the
audiences that they aim for reeves is
clearly being given free reign here and
this brand new look is absolutely
amazing the whole tone of it makes it
feel more like seven or silence of the
lambs instead of a comic book movie and
i had goosebumps while swatching it
which is definitely saying something
everything just seems part of this
gritty and grounded world i think next
year that it's really going to make an
impact and remind us that when dc12 they
have the skills to completely knock it
out the park i'm excited as a battle of
hell i feel like this trailer is going
to be something i'll watch again and
again and again 500 times in the next 10
minutes not going to sleep tonight now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer so make sure you comment
below and let me know as i said we're
going to be doing another breakdown
later in the week so make sure you drop
some of the easter eggs that we missed
below we are running competition right
now and giving away three copies of the
phase three mcu boxer on the 30th of
october and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if that's you if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of halloween kills which
will be linked on screen right now the
horror is it's it's got a lot of stuff
to talk about and obviously i'd love to
go through that with you so make sure
you head over there right after this if
not then thank you for sitting through
the video i hope you enjoy the rest of
your weekend and you take care of
yourself stay indoors the batman is
about and i'll see you on monday
peace